[Music]
next year is Big Brother 20 it has to be
all-stars if it isn't all-stars you guys
are seriously like come on it's 20 it
would be amazing do you want it to be
all-stars I do want it to be all-stars
and I wanted to be all-stars with me
watching from my home in Michigan eg on
set of a top-secret Big Brother comics
shoot with fan favorite former
houseguests who all wait in on the
possibility of coming back for another
go half million dollar prize definitely
maybe no one else you're gonna have that
kind of shot at a half a million dollars
do you want to come back and play
absolutely absolutely I mean I have I
have now lost eight reality TV
competitions always yeah I would you
know it's fine I would love for it to be
an all-star season I just played an
all-star on Survivor completely
different world completely different I
was like wow like I'm playing with the
big fish who would you like to see come
back and play again I think you have a
wide range of players you can bring back
I think you know people like Vanessa
someone like Derrick I think you could
see Rachel one more time and she could
even win again if they asked me to come
back for an all-star season I would most
definitely come back yeah I come back in
a heartbeat I go in there right now
[Music]